(jaunty music)
- Welcome royal punters
to "The Crown" Pub, grab a pint,
and get ready to play the
official "Crown" Pub Quiz.
Corgi related player names
are optional but welcomed.
You'll need to fetch a pen and paper
and grab some friends.
Answers will be given after each round.
So make sure you swap your sheets.
Any cheating will be frowned upon.
This quiz consists of
three rounds, trivia,
true or false, and guess who?
Ready?
Hit pause if you still need to find a pen.
Round one is all about episode one,
and it's about to start.
So we'll hand you over to our barman Tom.
(bell dinging)
- In what year did the first episode
of season three take place?
(clock ticking)
What is the value of the stamp
with Olivia Colman's portrait on it?
What was Harold Wilson's KGB code name?
What command does Philip
give Anthony Blunt
when he wants to give
the Queen a quick kiss?
What is the name of Margaret's new maid?
Which coin does Elizabeth remember
first seeing her father on?
What song does Margaret sing at the piano
while Tony is developing photos?
What is the graffiti slogan on the photo
that Tony is developing
while Margaret's singing
in the other room?
Which university did
Michael Straight attend?
- [Announcer] Big thanks to Tom
for that pint of trivia.
Now onto the bonus round
hosted by two very special punters.
You can score two points for
every answer you get correct.
(bell dinging)
Here we go.
- Who is the writer of "The Crown?"
- How did Princess Margaret
supposedly like to start her day?
- What is Queen Elizabeth's
favorite cocktail?
- [Announcer] Thanks to Josh and Erin
who just happened to be in
the pub at the right time.
Truly, what are the chances?
Now it's time to swap your
sheets and mark your answers.
Number one, 1964.
Number two, sixpence.
Number three, olding.
Number four "eyes left."
Number five, violet.
Number six, shilling.
Number seven, just one of those things.
Number eight, eat the rich!
Number nine, Cambridge.
And here are the bonus round answers.
Remember it's two points for each.
Number 10, Peter Morgan.
Number 11, you could have
having breakfast in bed,
listening to the radio,
or reading the papers.
Because we're giving you
two points for any of those.
Number 12, Dubonnet and gin.
OK, snatch back your answer
sheet and see how you did.
If you need an extra
minute, just hit pause.
Whenever you're ready, our
landlady and queen of drag
Jodie Harsh will take you
through the true or false round.
(bell dinging)
- True or false, costume designers
on "The Crown" had to
stitch the word sample
into every single outfit
that Claire Foy wore
to comply with counterfeiting laws
with regards to Her Majesty's likeness?
(brassy dance music)
True or false, set
designers on "The Crown"
had to especially custom design
the door of 10 Downing
Street for John Lithgow
because he's a foot taller than
Churchill was in real life.
True or false, Prince
Philip was such a big fan
of Mary Berry on "The
Great British Bake Off"
that he refuses to watch
the new Channel 4 series.
True or false, according
to an old golfing buddy
who caught a glimpse in the shower,
the Duke of Windsor has no pubic hair.
True or false, the
corgis on set are treated
even more lavishly than the
Queen's are, in real life.
They're treated to a three
course meal of rabbit,
duck, and grouse twice a day.
True or false, Helena Bonham
Carter is 59th in line
to the throne through her
uncle, Lord Bonham Carter.
True or false, because
fabric rationing was in place
when the Queen and Philip got engaged,
the Queen had to save up her ration cards
to get a wedding dress.
True or false, as well as
photographing the actual Queen,
photographer Tony Armstrong
Jones also shot the cover art
for "Queen's Greatest Hits" album.
- [Announcer] Thanks Jodie,
that round was truly harsh.
It's that time again.
Swap your sheets and get marking.
Here are your answers, number one, false.
Number two, true.
Number three, false.
Number four, true.
Number five, false.
Number six, false.
Number seven, true.
And number eight, true.
Answer sheets at the ready!
It's time for round three.
If you need a bit more
time, hit pause now.
When you're ready, Jodie's
back with the final round.
Get ready to guess who.
(bell dinging)
- Which royal is casually known
to her university friends as Sesh Gremlin?
(upbeat disco music)
Which royal created the
children's storybook character
Budgie the Little Helicopter?
Which royal had a real sweet tooth,
allegedly developing a daily habit
for Choco Leibniz biscuits?
Which royal allegedly had a
short-lived email relationship
with Britney Spears?
Which royal supposedly
hates horse racing so much
that they have a secret room at Ascot
where they can sneak off
and watch TV instead?
Which royal is said to
have once dressed up
in fighter pilot disguise to
enjoy an anonymous night out
down at Royal Vauxhall
Tavern with Freddie Mercury?
Which royal has a very simple rider
when making public appearances,
a can of full-fat Coke?
Which royal played tambourine
on the Gary Barlow track, "Sing?"
Which Royal is a keen reggae enthusiast
and a huge fan of Rihanna?
- [Announcer] OK, that's
the end of our quiz.
But before you go, swap
sheets, and get ready to mark.
'Cause here come the final answers.
Number one, Princess Eugenie.
Number two, Fergie.
Number three, Princess Margaret.
Number four, Prince William.
Number five, Prince Philip.
Number six, Lady Diana.
Number seven, Princess Anne.
Number eight, Prince Harry.
And number nine, Prince Charles.
Time to tot up your total marks out of 32.
Right, that's last orders.
Over to Jodie to close up.
- Well I hope you enjoyed the quiz.
Thanks for stopping by "The Crown."
And now it's time for
you to get outta my pub!